buycks he's a mess what's the one thing
you love about he's a mess
I love the meringues now this is a Eton
Mess with a twist
what's the twist in it compared to the
normal we're gonna freeze it so it's
almost like a sort of Eton Mess bomb now
I'd like you to whisk the cream please
half the strawberries are gonna go
through the mix and half of strawberries
gonna be turning to coulis strawberries
in first a little just think a box of
sugar into the pan and now the icing
sugar will withdraw the sweetness from
the strawberries and start caramelizing
it so let me show you a nice quick way
of whisking secret whiskey is like 10
seconds on 10 seconds off that way your
arms don't get tired now let's take the
cream to a three-quarter stage so we
leave some sort of texture in the cream
that's what we call 3/4 whip when you've
got a nice soft peak they're caramelized
then put a little touch of water in
there that'll help break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice so
liquid
now to get a really nice and fine on the
blender on and blitz off okay that's
fine
and when you use the back of the spoon
and push that through the sieve okay now
that way you don't get those seeds
smells so they're lovers now nice this
is the exciting part all right Oh Meg
us- vise now the meringue or your
fingers is crush and flake them right
into the cream how big should I crash it
died off good yeah nice big chunks okay
lovely okay to make this dessert even
easier I often cheat by using good
quality shop port meringues little taste
let's just cream em right wow said a
little tasty okay strawberries in next a
cup of spoons of the cooling now look at
that now
to prepare the mold to transform the
traditional Eton Mess into a frozen bomb
form a triple layer of cling film
and II water to the bowl will help the
cling film stick as I pour that in a way
to spread it down in the bottom and push
it down do you hear that crunch yeah all
right now fold attempt them over put
that in the freezer please make young
please in the freezer she goes run the
bowl under the hot water twist and pull
nice look at that you see it's amazing
sit that on to your plate now the
finishing touches a drizzle of the
remaining strawberry coulis - gonna pour
this over an amazing flavor and some
grated mint chocolate and that is a nice
twist on a classic Eton Mess a delicious
Eton Mess bomb beautiful let's get ready
please don't drop that neck please it's
not around as much